[Narrator] Welcome back to programming languages.
It's an exciting time, and the story thus far
we have already completed lexing and parsing,
but remember that our goal was ultimately to make a web browser?
Let's see how things are going towards that goal.
We are going to start with your average web page,
a string of HTML with some embedded Java script,
and we wanted to break it down into tokens or words,
and that process is called lexical analysis.
Once we have a bunch of tokens, we were going to parse those into a tree like one of these trees,
and that approach is called syntactic analysis or just parsing,
and now we want to walk that tree and understand it, and do useful work,
and this is called either symantics, a fancy word for meaning, or interpreting.
We want to look at this abstract syntax tree that has 5 and 3 as a child of plus,
and say that means 8.
And we want to do this for web pages, and the meaning that we're going to extract from them is what they look like.